-Donald Trump took the next step
in his slow-moving coup
over the weekend
when he went to Michigan
for a rally,
in part, to support fringe
state-level candidates
who support the big lie that
the 2020 election was stolen
and would wield power over
future elections in the state.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
The quasi-religious mythology
Trump's followers
have built around him
have now gotten
so detached from reality,
they're erasing
the things he has done
while giving him credit
for things he hasn't done.
For example, former
Vice President Mike Pence --
you know, the guy Trump
supporters threatened to hang
while Trump stood by silently --
said this over the weekend
on Fox News.
-President Biden has done
more damage to America
than any president
in modern history.
-Wow. How strict is your
definition of "modern history"?
[ As Pence ] Modern history
is everything since the slap.
[ Laughter ]
Then from 900 A.D. to the slap,
that's the Middle Ages.
[ Normal voice ] But seriously,
man, what's your deal?
You're still trying
to win over Trump voters?
They stormed the Capitol and
they chanted, "Hang Mike Pence."
That's you.
You're like a guy
who gets a fake number
from a woman at a bar
and keeps calling it,
hoping to get a date.
"Hello. Is Alice there?
Well, this is the number
she wrote on the bar napkin."
[ Laughter ]
"Well, you don't
have to be rude.
And can I just add,
I don't think kids
are old enough
to have their own cars."
Or maybe Pence thinks Biden
is worse than Trump
because he was asleep
during the entirety
of the Trump presidency,
which is possible,
given that in every meeting
he had his eyes closed
like he was desperately hoping
no one would notice him.
He's got his eyes closed like
he's trying not to throw up
on a state fair Tilt-A-Whirl.
These Trump toadies are all
such obsequious little worms,
but Pence's faux gravitas makes
him that much more insufferable,
the head shaking,
the solemn tone,
the put-on folksy demeanor.
He looks and moves
like a Chuck E. Cheese robot
who tells the band
to keep it down.
[ As Pence ] Fellas,
it's loud enough in here
with all the dang kids
screaming.
[ Normal voice ]
But Trump sycophants
aren't just trying to erase
his many failures,
they're also trying
to give him credit
for things
he had nothing to do with.
For example, on Saturday,
sitting member of Congress
Representative Lisa McClain
said at a Trump rally
in Michigan
that it was Trump
who had found Osama bin Laden.
-While President Trump
was in office,
we didn't have a war,
and I think he made
three peace treaties,
caught Osama bin Laden
and Soleimani, al-Baghdadi.
And this president is weak.
And I'll tell you,
weakness breeds aggression.
We need strength.
-Yeah, we need strength --
the kind of strength it takes
to find and kill
an elusive terrorist
while simultaneously
hosting a game show
with your wet,
asymmetrical sons.
Was finding bin Laden one of
the tasks on "The Apprentice"?
[ As Trump ] Jose Canseco,
you need to create
a 60-second commercial
for the new OnStar mirror.
And, Lisa Rinna, you're off
to Abbottabad, Pakistan...
[ Laughter ]
...to look for clues.
You can do it, Lisa.
[ Normal voice ] Seriously,
these people should have to take
the same kind of tests
to stay in Congress
that you give a boxer to make
sure they can stay in the fight.
"How many fingers
am I holding up?" "16."
"What year is it?"
"3069."
"Who killed Osama bin Laden?"
"Donald Trump."
"Okay, we're calling it."
Would you seriously not remember
that famous photo
where Barack Obama,
Hillary Clinton, and Joe Biden
were in the situation room
watching the raid
as it happened?
Is there some Photoshop version
floating around
on the QAnon forums
where Trump is sitting
in the middle of the picture
in that stance he always has,
like he's trying to crowd out
the people next to him
on the subway?
"Excuse me.
Can you move?
I need at least
an entire row to myself.
I can't close my legs.
I have to have my back-back
on the ground.
It's also especially
galling to give Trump credit
for catching bin Laden,
given that Trump himself
dismissed it
as a non-accomplishment
when the admiral in charge
of the raid, William McRaven,
publicly criticized Trump
during his presidency.
-Bill McRaven, retired admiral,
Navy SEAL, 37 years,
former head
of U.S. Special Operations...
-Hillary Clinton fan.
-...Special Operations...
-Excuse me.
Hillary Clinton fan.
-...who led the operations,
commanded the operations
that took down Saddam Hussein
and that killed Osama bin Laden,
says that your sentiment is
the greatest threat to democracy
in his lifetime.
-Okay.
He's a Hillary Clinton backer
and an Obama backer,
and, frankly...
-He was a Navy SEAL.
-...wouldn't it have been nice
if we got Osama bin Laden
a lot sooner than that?
Wouldn't it have been nice?
You know, living --
Think of this --
living in Pakistan,
beautifully in Pakistan
in what I guess
they considered a nice mansion.
I don't know.
I've seen nicer.
-Alright, couple of things.
First of all, stop shouting
"Hillary Clinton fan"
like a guy on "Wheel of Fortune"
who insists his answer is right.
[ As Trump ] Pat, I'd like
to solve the puzzle.
Hillary Clinton fan.
[ Buzzer ]
[ Normal voice ] Okay,
let's turn around the letters,
and we see that the answer is...
[ As Trump ] Uhhhh...
Hillary Clinton fan.
[ Buzzer ]
[ Normal voice ] Also, let's
go back to this for a second,
because this is
a perfect Trump sentence.
-Living in Pakistan,
beautifully in Pakistan
in what I guess
they considered a nice mansion.
I don't know.
I've seen nicer.
-He wants to shame McRaven for
not catching bin Laden sooner
by saying he was living
in a beautiful mansion.
But he also can't stop himself
from [bleep] on the mansion.
And look, like everyone,
I was upset
when I heard bin Laden
was living in a mansion,
and then I saw it and thought,
"Okay.
That makes me feel
a little bit better."
On a smaller scale,
it's how I feel
when I see a picture of Trump
at the omelet bar
at his golf club.
Sure, he's a free man, but those
look like [bleep] eggs,
and that makes me smile
a little bit.
Also, it's pretty rich for Trump
to insinuate the admiral
who caught the world's
most wanted terrorist
should have done it sooner,
considering we're still waiting
on the tax returns
Trump promised us in 2016.
Maybe Obama had to wait for
the raid for the same reason
we're still waiting for that.
"We know where he is,
Mr. President,
but our intel tells us
he's being audited by the IRS."
[ As Obama ] Well, then
we, uh...have to wait.
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ] Anyway,
McClain made that comment
in Michigan over the weekend
at yet another one of Trump's
unhinged rallies.
And at first, it may have seemed
like a typical Trump rally,
not worth paying
much attention to,
given that most of it
was his usual shtick.
For example, Trump did
that thing he always does
where he says something,
then predicts that the media
will criticize him
for saying it.
-I knew Putin very well.
You know, they say,
"Oh, he knows Putin.
He knows Putin. Oh."
That's a good thing,
not a bad thing.
I know Kim Jong-un.
I know President Xi of China.
-Why are you just listing
off people, you know?
You sound like a 5-year-old
rattling off
which dinosaur stickers he has.
"I got triceratops.
I got brontosaurus.
I got doubles of pterodactyl."
Also, no one is mad
that you know dictators.
They're mad because you admire
and seek to emulate them.
You've constantly lavished
praise on Vladimir Putin
as he criminally interfered
in American democracy
and waged a brutal war on
an innocent neighboring country.
And in general, you're clearly
desperate to mimic autocrats,
like during a previous rally
when Trump said
President Xi of China was smart
because he rules his country
like a ruthless tyrant.
-You know, every time I say
somebody's smart,
they always go, "Oh, Trump said
that President Xi of China
is smart."
Well, you know,
he runs 1.5 billion people
with an iron fist.
Yeah, I think he's pretty smart.
And they have a chain
over there.
You know, if you're a dummy,
you get left here.
It's like this.
It's like a pyramid.
The smartest one
gets to the top.
-I think you're confusing
a dictatorship
with a cheerleading squad.
[ As Trump ] They put the
smartest cheerleader at the top
because then
if the pyramid collapses,
maybe you lose a few idiots.
But Becky still
goes to Princeton.
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ]
Although I'm guessing
there are some similarities.
"Janice, if you don't get
your [bleep] together
and nail this basket toss,
we are not going to make state."
By the way, you might think
because I'm a 48-year-old man
and a father of three, I haven't
seen the movie "Bring It On."
But guess what.
You're wrong.
Because it came out
22 years ago,
when I was childless and happy.
In fact, I would even --
Look, I love my kids.
I just haven't seen that movie
in like a month.
In fact, I would even
go so far to say
that Trump wants to turn our
democracy into a cheerocracy.
And that's today's unnecessary
"Bring It On" reference.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Also, I love Trump's theory
that the dummies
get left at the bottom
in a dictatorship.
Let's hope Rudy Giuliani never
has to find his way to the top
in a Trump dictatorship.
-From the top to the bottom,
from the middle to the side.
[ As Giuliani ] Good news --
They told me I'm going to be
all the way up here at the top
because I'm smart.
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ]
That's such a revealing window
into Trump's worldview.
If you're a tyrant who rules
with an iron fist,
that makes you smart,
well, democracy is for suckers.
In fact, at his Michigan rally,
Trump even joked about
what it would have sounded like
if he'd conceded,
mocking it like
it was some dumb idea.
-Be a lot easier
for me to say, "Oh."
Be a lot easier for me to do
like many people have done,
get up and just say
congratulations,
whoever it is
I'm running against.
I mean, if you're running,
I'd say, "Congratulations, Joe."
-Why is his Trump impression
so bad?
[ Laughter ]
So every everyone
has a Donald Trump
except Donald Trump?
He sounds like Vincent D'Onofrio
from "Men in Black."
[ Muttering indistinctly ]
[ Laughter ]
[ As Trump ] I think my Trump's
getting pretty good.
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ] Like that,
what you're doing right now.
[ As Trump ] What,
like I'm doing right now.
No, this isn't.
[ Mutters indistinctly ]
That's how I sound.
[ Normal voice ] To Trump, the
idea of conceding when you lose
is laughable.
It's a joke,
only something suckers do.
And that's why he was
really there --
for his ongoing attempt
to end American democracy
and install himself or whoever
the next Republican nominee is
as an unelected autocrat.
Because by his own admission,
Trump was there in part
to campaign for state-level
GOP candidates
who have embraced the big lie
and would wield power
over Michigan's elections
in 2024 if they win.
And even by Trump's
own admission,
it was unusual that he was there
for that reason.
-Remember, this is not
just about 2022.
This is about making sure
Michigan is not rigged
and stolen again in 2024.
I have to be honest,
I don't do this often.
I don't do this often
for state people.
This is so important.
What happened in Michigan
is a disgrace.
-Once again, the guy just admits
it all in public.
He's like a guy robbing a bank
saying, "I don't do this often.
Usually I just take money
out of the ATM.
But the ATM only lets you
take your own money.
I mean, what's the deal
with that?"
And it's not just Michigan.
Republicans are doing this
across the country
in preparation
for the next coup.
-This morning, the Associated
Press published an expansive
and very well-reported story
on the attack on our democracy.
This is the headline --
"Slow-Motion Insurrection:
How the Republican Party
Seizes Election Power."
As the AP describes it...
-First of all, of course
it's a slow-motion insurrection.
Everything Trump does
is in slow motion.
Remember when he used to
just wander around
the White House lawn
like a dad in the backyard
looking for some weeds to spray?
So may be slow motion,
but it's definitely happening.
It's something most people
don't realize
but Trump has figured out,
because our elections
are decentralized.
If you want to subvert them,
you have to install loyalists
in those local positions
across the country
like secretary of state.
Remember how Trump
tried to shake down
the Georgia secretary of state
to help him steal votes?
Well, now Trump is backing
a challenger
who supports the big lie,
just like he's doing in Michigan
and several other states
across the country.
Republicans are still
very much engaged
in their slow-moving coup,
and this is their playbook.
They've figured out
that if you want
to install yourself at the top,
you need loyal
foot soldiers at...
-The bottom.
[ Laughter ]
-He passed the bar.
This has been "A Closer Look."
God's Love We Deliver cooks
and brings
over 2 million meals a year
to men, women, and children
living with HIV/AIDS, cancer,
and other serious illnesses.
And they need your help
now more than ever.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the "donate" button.
Stay safe, get vaccinated.
We love you.